joining me now are feel good foundation
president john phil
and someone i have to confess to having
been a fan of for many years
uh the one and only jon stewart thank
you both uh for joining me
uh john you're both called john's it's
confusing jon stewart
john stewart let me kick off with you
first you guys have been campaigning to
help 911 responders with illnesses
and veterans who serve near burn pits in
iraq and afghanistan
what is the common thread there why do
these twin issues
compel you in particular uh well first
of all thanks so much for
for having us on and and certainly uh
john feel has been uh
tireless in these efforts for the past
15 years
uh going down to washington dc over 150
times and
bringing first responders uh i what
happened was
after uh the lobbying efforts for this
droga act
we were contacted by someone from an
organization called burn pits 360
a woman named rosie torres whose husband
leroy torres was
an iraq war veteran who would have been
exposed to burn pits
what they were finding was a very
similar
kind of cadre of illnesses and injuries
to their lungs and these cancers very
similar to what the 911 first responders
have
and uh the common thread were these
toxic exposures through jet fuel
burning because the burn pits are uh
accelerated by jet fuel which is
obviously
what accelerated the fires on 9 11. so
uh we we you know went down there and
said hey whatever we could do to help
out you know
john has developed a really excellent
blueprint
in terms of advocating for these
legislative fixes
and and so we've tried to apply that
model
uh to the iraq and afghanistan war
veterans
john phil you founded the feel good
foundation you've also joked
uh that someone had to tell you how to
spell foundation but you've been hugely
successful
uh what do you bring to this campaign
and what does
john bring i wonder how you complement
each other in this work that you do
well um let me echo what john says and
uh thank you for having me
um i bring uh
the ability not to accept no when people
are suffering
i know how to get under the skin of
members of congress in the senate
and the fact that they think i'm capable
of violence
and never used violence um it's good
enough
i mean i'm a kidney donor to a complete
stranger i'm a pacifist
but when you show them that you have
nothing to lose um
and you're not going away and you can
outlast their career
i've been at this for 16 years i've had
over 1800 meetings over 300 trips to dc
i know every square inch of capitol hill
isn't i know
when they're going to go to the bathroom
when they're going to have lunch i
get in their head and i make their lives
miserable we're talking
about men and women who do extraordinary
things to keep us safe 24 7. and that's
just not the veterans
around the world doing that in the
soldiers that was 9 11 responders as
well
law enforcement firefighters it wasn't
just ground zero it was also the
pentagon in shanksville
every time these men and women go to
combat or get hurt in a
shootout or in a fire we call them
heroes but when they come home
they're expendable and then they become
a statistic and they become a
financial burden on the uh on the
municipality we got to stop this
you know we keep saying thank you we say
thank you for your service
we say thank you for a job well done and
i think it's unintentional but that
thank you was shallow
and um not everybody can help like jon
stewart or john field and they don't
have the energy or the resources
but thank you to me just doesn't cut it
anymore because we just
we overuse it without getting involved
and to really say thank you
is to get involved and get off our butts
because we're getting lazy and people
are suffering and we need
everybody now more than ever with this
piece of legislation to step forward and
help us
you say about john phil just sticking
with you say everyone needs to step
board and help you
according to the va last month more than
200 000 veterans
have signed on to the department's burn
pit database uh nearly 13 000 vets have
filed burn pit related disability claims
and yet only 2 800 claims have been
approved
according to va figures from last month
so nearly 80 percent of those claims
have been rejected
what is going on there well if you were
a major league baseball player you'd be
getting a 12 million dollar contract
with those statistics
listen um they've they failed
the va's failed the dod's failed
congress has failed the senate's failed
several administrations have failed and
john and i
with the vsos and the american people
and members of congress in the senate
we're gonna fix this we're gonna correct
this um failure is not an option
these men and women need help now it's
that simple
so it's your job as a journalist to
continue to tell this story
long after me and john get off of the
show tonight to ensure that we keep this
going into next year
whether we have the same administration
or a new administration
we need to get this done these people
have been walking the halls of congress
as long as i have and got nowhere
and if john feel with somebody with the
iq of around room for temperature
can get 13 pieces of legislation passed
than anybody else can
um john stewart when you got permanent
funding for the 911 victims compensation
fund
two senators held the bill up and voted
against it republicans
rand paul and mike lee who complained
about the cost
lee is also one of several high-profile
republicans who recently contracted
covet 19
and received top flight and very free
medical care courtesy of the federal
government how does that make you feel
isn't that a double standard
well i think one of the issues uh that
occurs with the
republican party unfortunately is
nothing is real until it happens to them
um it's an inability to empathize or to
understand
that uh other people may be suffering
issues that you don't suffer in the same
way that they discuss entitlements you
know for a republican
an entitlement is just money spent on
something you don't need
but if you need it well then it's it's
necessary and it's patriotic
and certainly uh you know mike lee was
one of the more difficult
senators that john and i had to deal
with down there along with mitch
mcconnell and quite frankly most of the
republican leadership
again we're trying to address here a
structural issue
in the way that we go to war
you know if you look at the pentagon
budget the pentagon budget is around 800
billion dollars the pentagon has an
80 billion dollar oco slush fund it's
basically
the you know the overseas contingency
operations fund the big
it's utterly unaccountable well that's
850
billion dollars but when people come
back and they're suffering from
a lung injuries and cancers absolutely
related to their service
the va's position is to deny and to
delay
is to they function like a really
stringent insurance company
to try and prevent people from getting
it you know these soldiers
are are basically put on trial so you go
in and you say okay i'm having trouble
breathing right
uh i can no longer do the physical tasks
that i used to be able to do
well you have to face a medical board
you have to be your own scientist your
own doctor your own lawyer
meanwhile the pentagon your own advocate
the pentagon has utterly no oversight
and no accountability for these 850
billion dollars
but each individual soldier is put under
a microscope the va
shouldn't be functioning as the
insurance company they should be
functioning as the advocate
they're the ones that shouldn't be
denying claims they're the ones that
should be
uh lobbying the pentagon to
uphold their part of the deal these
soldiers
upheld their part of the deal they
served this country
sorry i was gonna ask how do you square
what you're describing about
mike lee and mitch mcconnell republican
leadership how do you square that
description with the description
that republicans have always reveled in
both voters and elected politicians
we are the party of the military we are
the party of the police we are the party
of firefighters we are the parties
of people in uniform how does that mean
it's it's it's paper patriotism it's the
party that
uh you know if colin kaepernick takes a
knee they'll never watch
another football game again they'll
never go there they
stand uh for the anthem but when it
comes down
you know everybody supports the troops
until the troops need support
and then they disappear and it's too
much money
we can no longer always have money for
war
and then not have enough money for the
war fighter this should be part and
parcel the way that we
go to war it's not as though these toxic
exposures or these illnesses or these
things
is a new phenomenon in society you know
we've been dealing with this since world
war
ii and korea they're vietnam veterans
who are still trying to get benefits due
to agent orange exposure through the va
there are persian gulf veterans
who are still trying to get uh for gulf
war syndrome
benefits in health care through the va
everybody thinks you
are in the military you get healthcare
for life you don't
you get it for a certain small period of
time
and then unless your health condition is
deemed to be
uh in the line of service or tied to
your duty you get nothing
and that that's what this is all about
delaying and denying
to keep people from getting the services
that they need
so that we can save some money on we are
balancing
the budget for war on the backs of sick
soldiers there's no other way to put it
um john field just yesterday a park in
long island was dedicated to the memory
of luis alvarez an nypd detective who
was a friend to both of you
who accompanied you to capitol hill and
who succumbed to his 911 related illness
not long afterwards it's an important
gesture but what else do you wish
americans and their elected officials
would do
to fulfill their debt to victims like
detective alvarez
well i mean it'd be easy to say uh just
remember but i think that's become a
bumper sticker right so
um you know again um not everybody has
the resources of a jon stewart or the
energy and the time of a john feel but
people can get involved and if it's not
just 9 11 of veterans and get involved
in an issue that affects americans
lou is a great friend um even at my park
on long island
i named a 17 foot high clock after him
um my dog is named lou ray for lou
alvarez and rape fight for both who
passed away from 9 11 cancer
but you know people need to start
volunteering you know
911 was the second largest act of
volunteerism
ever next to the civil war and um didn't
matter our skin color
religion our gender our pay scale
of political affiliation we all came
together as americans and as human
beings
and um i'm a strong believer that
charity over
overcomes evil and i'm sure and believe
it that good triumphs over evil
and i think we're gonna start healing
ourselves as a nation when more and more
people can get involved with serious
issues that we face
as a nation like these veterans coming
back from the burn pits and um
you know next in two weeks john and i
are going to get honored by the pat
tillman foundation
and it's it's almost embarrassing for me
to be honored by a military organization
because i haven't done anything yet and
they want to honor me for
past work of 15 years um
i'm embarrassed because i would rather
them honor us next year
when we do get something done and i
guarantee i will bet my one kidney
we get this done um but to be mentioned
in the same sentence as pat tillman
who is the most tenacious football
player i ever seen
play football how to how i lobbied
congress with tenacity to be mentioned
with pat
and john in the same sentence uh i think
i'm the only person in america that's
ever been mentioned in the same sentence
as those two and um
that's a that's an honor enough
uh john john stewart covid also poses
special challenges to 911
and burn pit survivors especially with
the respiratory issues did you ever
imagine at the beginning of the outbreak
that we would be here in the fall
approaching the winter with more than
200 000 americans dead
and more grim projections add that it
would be so mishandled
in the united states of america no
and it's i mean look it's
i respect that we've not dealt with
something like
this previously
but the vacuum of leadership
at the top of this pandemic is so
stunning the fact that we have no
national strategy uh that there's no
that we did not mobilize to the extent
of
of like a world war ii effort with a a
federal
program to create and and manufacture
ppe to uh build out a testing protocol i
mean that would be the way
to reopen the economy in a much safer
manner is if the federal government got
behind
uh an enormous world war ii like effort
of increasing rapid testing it's it's
the only way that
that you can open you know right now
we're we're flying without instruments
it's it's in the fog and we have no
instruments
we have the scientific capability of
attacking this
in a much shrewder way but at the top of
the leadership there's
there's no plan other than every now and
again making fun of somebody for wearing
a mask or
tweeting out liberate michigan it's
it's such nonsense you know and john and
i are going to go down
uh to dc on veterans day and
we're going to try and rally the
veterans community to make sure that you
know people are dealing with
so much right now between the the
pandemic
and the economic crisis uh that we just
want to try and keep
this effort because these soldiers covet
is especially dangerous
to those that have suffered uh lung
injury
from their service in afghanistan and
iraq so uh we're gonna go down there
on november i'm sorry go ahead
and no i'm gonna have to jump in because
we're out of time but thank you so much
jon stewart and john field thank you for
your awesome work thank you for coming
on the show tonight